[Musik]
das wahre Leben ist sich für andere
einzusetzen wir die Pflegefachkräfte von
morgen mit kogniturl der Versicherer für
Gesundheit und Vorsorge
[Musik]
vielleicht rettet Ihnen eine vor deiner
jungen Mannschaft
sie sind Orgien die Flagge von Kraft
oder rettichsanität
ige ist der Burg spannend aber
ausspruchsvoll Rebecca
Fanny
und deliker werden in der Branche
geschaffen wo viele andere verlernt
warum
das erzählt dir sehr lieb wir die
Pflegefachkräfte von morgen
[Musik]
laufend bestens au will dir Studierende
sich gut verstand in der
Gesundheitsprüfung
ist natürlich
[Musik]
genau
[Gelächter]
stimmig ist gut Müller
konzentrieren jetzt kurz um ein größerer
Umfall wo es zwei fürware und vier
Krankenwagen
wer mitmachen
tambulanz ist 144 gemeldeten
neben den Autos und mehrere Insassen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
zum Beruhigen auf die Art
okay
[Musik]
Toni muss für Währung hilft bitte aber
sie zögert
den Strukturen notiert sich jede
Minute
[Applaus]
sage ich falsch positioniert und Glas
zerspringt die musikschärfe
das Glas für später
[Applaus]
so etwas passiert
[Musik]
ja sie blutet
[Applaus]
abgemacht Windschutzscheibe und nicht
ja
die andere Gruppe macht weiter und wirkt
die Verletzten
[Musik]
[Applaus]
der Abtransport von der Kollegin ist
richtig voll klar später rund um gut los
geht's
so hier jetzt muss sie nur die
Plastikpuppe fixieren und deine stirbig
für Pony abgeschlossen
fahre
vom Rettungsdienst
[Applaus]
[Musik]
das ist jetzt schon passiert ist
unter der Studierende von sich stimmig
okay
morgenstimmige Ausbildungszentrum von
der Lausanne
sie ist 21 und im dritten Frau
die
Sensibilität gehört
ich glaube das ist es
einfach nur XI
Klinik Klasse
spitalpraktikum
studieren die mit dem Bachelor alles
normal
[Musik]
da dann Behandlung durchführen
und praktische für die wo im letzten
Ausbildungsjahr sind
im schuluntergeschoss hat sich
zahnpatientinnen und Patienten parat
gemacht nehme das wirklich krank sie
spielen der Rolle der Daniel nimmt den
Alzheimer-Patient
hallo
[Musik]
genau wie ein richtiges spitalalltag
treffen sich morgen alle zu Besprechung
[Musik]
ich darf Vitamin B drüber du da hast und
schon laut
der Alzheimer Patienten
ganz viel machen
wirklich so extrem gut
und sie reagieren
Grüße
[Applaus]
während Mile probierte Herr solists
einfach im Verlauf von morgen wenn der
Hunger bekommen
[Musik]
Internet nachgeguckt und gemeint dass er
wirklich wirklich
die Situation
im achte spitalalltag betreut Pflege
da betreut zwei und das ist schon knurrt
vor allem mit alzheimerkrankungen
also wenn es gleich betroffen ist dann
ist es mehr als das
hier die Patientin Angst von einer
Amputation hat
warum sie ist und trink doch
eigentlich ist sie nicht und hat immer
weniger Hunger
ist fertig
Schauspielerinnen und Schauspieler
berichtet der Ausbildnerin vorhin
sehr freundlich zu
unterstützt sehr verstanden
ich rede sehr gut betreut
sie sind sehr dampft aber auch
konsequent und können auf Bedürfnisse
aber sie tun da ihre Kolleginnen
der DR Garcia beurteilt wir dir
Studierenden
sich wirklich gut
mit der Maske
aus
krank sind bitte Ente ist es zwar nicht
schlimmes aber das geht doch schwer
Krankheiten das macht psychologisch
nicht einfach wenn man also trotzdem mit
der Größe Richtigkeit auf Patienten
zugeht kann man besser schaffen gute
Stimmung bringt zum Beispiel sicher mehr
als Mitleid oder
beim Patient oder
Wochenend
aber mit Olli hat das Wochenende
Rebecca dreht aber kein Wissen sondern
danke
ja genau
rebecca ist immer gut gelohnt und
dynamisch aber sie hat es nicht immer
einfach kommen als Jugendliche hat sie
im fründker wo sie geschlagen hat und
ihre Mutter ist gestorben
[Musik]
dass sie gar nicht
geschmissen sondern das ganze
stimmt
sondern ganz ganz
viel für mich
entschieden und du bist
und so bin ich der Kranken
schönen Tag für mich jeden Morgen ich
will nicht ich
muss ein bisschen machen
und mir treffen Rebecca im Genfer
Universitätsspital wo sie ihres letzte
Praktikum macht
aber ich bin voll konzentriert
[Gelächter]
wurde
Abteilung
ein einziger kleine Fehlerchen die
enorme folgen
aber irgendwie trotzdem wird es
blockiert ich bin nicht entspannt und
überlege die ganze Zeit aber ich sag
jetzt richtig gemacht okay
[Musik]
alles gut
okay
und links Anja völlig konzentriert auf
das was sie macht Verstärker
ich kontrolliere aber nicht Zugang
sie ist nicht immer einfach wenn man in
der Ausbildung ist und dazu eine
Erfahrung und wüsstet ihr wie man
Patienten motivieren und überzeugen kann
bis Zusteller wo immer gut tut
mir klingt das nicht immer und dann sage
ich halt gut
es ist wichtig dass wir nicht vergessen
dass Patienten selber entscheiden
okay gut dann würde ich jetzt an der
Blutdruck messen
[Musik]
ger
so jetzt haben
gut und das bedeutet
[Musik]
spritzt in ihre Frau richtig ja genau
perfekt wenn ich zum Arzt kann sage ich
mein geschaut ja okay und nach einer
Hand die verstanden
[Gelächter]
einmal alles genau dort zum sicher klar
dass alles klar ist und Sie wissen was
machen bei meinem Mann
und Medikament
anerkennen die Wort für Flagge fachlüht
aber die haben gar keine Zeit dafür
rebecca ist schon wieder unterwegs auf
ihrem Marathon Durchgang hallo
[Gelächter]
ist unterwegs zum
[Musik]
kontrolliert zusammen mit dem
hilfspflagger das sie gut betätigt und
lernt auch noch Spital
[Applaus]
so ez-blatt
ist gut so
mit euch morgen
ist gut
informieren sich im Büro wer alles neu
hat zwar alles übersättigt
Notfallsituationen gelernt ich habe
gerade verloren Termine
was passiert ist
wirklich verloren
ganz plötzlich
das ist mir vor längerem mal passiert es
sieht und ich bin nicht umgeht plötzlich
beruhigt sie und dass mir ihre Kinder
und die ganze Familie informiert hätte
und falls Sie mir ist der Gott
und fragiler und darum ging es jetzt
sehr schon sehr mehrere wichtig müssen
klar machen das ist jetzt die erste
Linie um eriksundheit geht
vorbereitet er konzentriert sich auf
seine Notizen
ja heute morgen
aber Kollegin von Nachtschicht die hat
sich gesehen
ganze Familie mit dem Virus angesteckt
oder umgekehrt ja aber sie ist total
ja das war's auch noch vielen Dank alles
klar
aber so eine Arzt Visite ist für alle
Studierende innere Vorträge es gibt auch
bei dir so Frage wo man nicht
mitgerechnet hat und der tankt man
mischt da habe ich nicht drauf geachtet
nicht drüber
nein
stressig aber im positiven Sinn
guten Tag
Grüße
Familie von der Rosmarie hat gerade
alles erfahren
[Musik]
genau
ehrlich gesagt
kurze Zeit kann ich nicht sagen ob sie
wirklich laufen wie vorher oder ob sie
Hecher ich habe da nicht so aus dem
Fenster lernen ich würde sagen Leute
zieht zum krafttraum und der Luger mehr
wie bitte persona
und betreue Patientin
ja klar ich kann die bitte noch euch
Koordinaten haben dass man könnte
erreichen wenn es nötig wäre
Informationen dass man schon hey
das ist wichtig
der ist aufgeschrieben
sehr gern
die Frage beantwortet und alles Gute
erklärt hat
die Koordinaten
wir versuchen einfach Glück beruhigend
informieren so viel wie immer als
pflegen
wirklich sehr besorgt ist dann verbindet
man die Person mit dem Arzt oder der
Arzt in wozu ständig ist und ich wünsche
information
danke
[Musik]
Jennifer übernimmt jetzt Betreuung von
der Rosmarie
alles klar
[Musik]
Fröhlichkeit und Energie wo junge
berufslied mitbringen helfen
in der nächsten Folge
[Musik]
Nervosität auch im Luca wo sind die Vene
und bitte den Wecker reiht sich
Nachtschicht an Nachtschicht
[Musik]
das war wir die Pflegefachkräfte von
morgen mit kognituren der Versicherer
für Gesundheit und Vorsorge